نحن هنا في منطقه بين منطقه بين بلده
نورداغ وايضا قريه قريبه تدعى ترك اوغلو
هذه المنطقه تربط بينها سكه حديديه هذه
السكه الحديديه كان هناك صوره انتشرت عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بعد الزلزال كانت
هذه الصوره تظهر السكه الحديديه التي تربط
ما بين هاتاي او مناطق في هاتاي وغازي
عنتاب وبعض مناطق مرعش حيث انحنت السكه
بشكل كبير نحن في هذا الموقع بالضبط نايف
قبل ان اتحدث عن
قبل ان اجب عن سؤالك كما نشاهد تم اصلاح
السكه حاليا لكن طبعا حركه القطارات ما
زالت متوقفه لكن انا هنا كما نشاهد هنا
السكه القديمه التي انحنت بشكل كبير وهنا
تحت هذه الجرافه هذه هي السكه التي ظهرت
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في صوره
شهيره لانحناء السكه بشكل كبير وتضرر سكه
القطار بسبب الزلزال كما نشاهد في هذه
المنطقه التي اقف انا عليها هذه السكه شده
الانحناء الكبيره بسبب الزلزال والتي
تضررت بشكل كبير هذه سكه الحديد وتوقفت عن
العمل قبل ان تقوم السلطات التركيه باعاده
اصلاحها وترميمها هذا هو بعض الاثار التي
تظهر بسبب الزلزال اثار الدمار الذي ضرب
البنيه التحتيه هنا في ولايه غازي عنتاب
نايف لا ادري اذا كانت الصوره قريبه بما
فيه الكفايه لترى حجم الانحناء الكبير في
السكه الحديد في السكه الحديديه